hey leute und willkommen zu einer neuen
mode review es ist mittlerweile wirklich
echt extrem schwermut zu finden die
schon für die 1.3.1 draußen sind daher
wollte ich euch heute nun mal einen mord
vorstellen den ich so noch gar nicht
kannte und zwar schaut euch das mal an
die blöcke drehen sich das ist extrem
geil also solche blöcke die ua nein nein
nein du dich eigentlich wenn man jetzt
zb irgendwie so eine tür hin schmeißt
dann guckt die einen die ganze zeit an
egal wenn man irgendwie um die rumläuft
und so weiter allerdings ist dieser 3d
items motto heißt er nämlich der macht
quasi dass diese blöcke sich drehen das
sieht ich habe einfach mal so ein paar
items ins inventar geholt bei denen das
ganze interessant aussieht also hier zum
beispiel so ein blog ist noch relativ
normal dass der sich dreht aber dann
eine spitzhacke sieht schon ganz cool
aus auch von der breite ist alles ganz
okay hier bei den sachen auch noch alles
ganz in ordnung bei der tür sich das
auch ganz witzig aus wenn man dann auch
noch durch die durchgucken kann beim
glas kann man dann natürlich auch durch
gucken
auch wenn ich irgendwie an summe das
passt schon alles und ich hatte diesen
fokus tick bot auch nochmal reingepackt
um zu sehen ob das auch bei items klappt
die in durch muss hinzugefügt wurden und
dabei klappt es auch also das ist echt
extrem cool dass dieser mord wirklich
die kompatibilität mit anderen mods
alles besitzt nur das ist jetzt hier
wieder so eine sache da finde ich hätte
der modchip daran arbeiten können oder
hier beim kuchen und zwar wenn man sich
die anguckt die sind zwar so von der
textur her richtig aber die sind nur ein
blog bereit das heißt sondern kuchen ist
für mich eigentlich sollten ja keine
ahnung also wenn jetzt hinkriegen würde
müsste er natürlich noch die texturen
alles mögliche verändern aber dass wir
jetzt für mich zum beispiel so ein
verbesserungsvorschlag an den mod
hersteller dass man zum beispiel diesen
kuchen nicht ein breit macht sondern
wirklich wie sollen wir so einen kuchen
auch aussehen lässt also rund sage ich
mal die sonne
wieso einen block von den verhältnissen
sag ich mal was war ganz cool wenn er es
hinkriegen würde hier mit passions und
so funktioniert auch alles ist ganz cool
ich weiß gar nicht was sie gerade macht
aber ich glaube ich habe eine feier
resistenz ist sehr schön
naja egal jedenfalls war das jetzt
wirklich eine extrem kurze vorstellung
wenn ihr weitere mans zwist die für die
1.3.1
und fertig sind die ich vielleicht
vorstellen soll da sind kakaobohnen wenn
irgendwelche weiteren mods wird die ich
vorstellen soll die auch schon für die
1.3 fertig sind schreibt mir wie immer
unten in die kommentare
und dann würde ich sagen mit diesem
tollen blick auf diese tolle items und
jetzt ich probiert es doch unglaublich
ich würde sagen wir sehen uns beim
nächsten mal tschüss bis zum nächsten
mal ich würde mich über ein tor freuen
bis zum nächsten mal bis zum nächsten
mal bis zum nächsten mal
ach so was ich noch sagen wollte fällt
mir grad auf ich sage die ganze zeit bis
zum nächsten mal
naja ist es relativ früh am morgen und
ich bin noch ein bisschen verplant aber
was ich noch sagen wollte ist thema
games kommen und zwar haben sich viele
gefragt warum ich denn donnerstag jetzt
doch nicht da war und so weit dass er
geschrieben hat und zwar hatte ich
totale mandl schmerzen
ich hab mich hier gerade mit die heißt
das wenn dann strip sinnvoll sind so
lutschtabletten und ich hoffe dass das
am sonntag besser wird weil am sonntag
komme ich auf jeden fall dahin mit drei
freunden und dann treffen uns auch mit
denen und ich denke ihr werdet mich
schon irgendwie erkennen also ich bin
sonntag auf der gamescom auch auf dem
video day und dann würde ich sagen bis
zum nächsten video ich würde mich aber
daumen hoch freuen und ciao